saying in the United States the
presidential election there is a year
away and Donald Trump could be heading
for a tough race an average of all the
opinion polls puts Trump's approval
rating at just above 41% but much more
ominously for him almost 55 percent of
Americans disapprove of the job he's
doing a key question is who will Trump
face in the 2020 election most polls
predict that if it's former Vice
President Joe Biden Trump will lose but
many polls suggest the more progressive
Democratic candidate Elizabeth Warren
could also have a slight edge over Trump
opinion polls are one way of assessing
which way the election could go another
is to look at bellwether regions
Richland County in Wisconsin has proved
to be a reliable indicator since 1980
the county has always voted for the
winning candidate so DW correspondent
Oliver sallet traveled to Richland to
gauge the mood feeding time for dairy
farmer mark stalls and his calves like
most people in Richland County Stoltz
voted for president Trump in 2016 but
twice for Barack Obama in the elections
before this time he says the political
mood is anything but clear we tend to we
tend to like Trump more than most people
and so I don't I we don't talk a whole
lot about it but it can get very testy
very quickly and even within our family
even though he voted for Trump in the
last election mark stalls cares about
key Democratic issues like health care
and climate change he also wants an end
to the president's trade war which has
hit farmers like him particularly hard
he says so that that's hurt we don't
have a good place to ship milk and whey
products and cheese and you know so
right now the markets got a lot of milk
and cheese on it and Americans are
drinking less milk now Wisconsin lost
over 600 dairy farms in the last year
Richland Center with its 5,000 citizens
is the largest town in Richland County a
bellwether for the presidential election
since 1980
the majority here has always voted for
the winning
a date Richland County is traditionally
a Republican County do we always vote
that way no I wouldn't vote for him I
don't like him I doesn't think he I
think if he keep his mouth shut and stay
off of Twitter he would be fun I think
it's with all the impeachment so if it's
gonna be very noisy and interesting for
the next year but if I was betting today
I would bet he'll get elected again at
the local newspaper editor Don Keefer
says left and right wing supporters in
the county are fighting for the public's
attention she is often criticized for
printing opinion letters that are too
critical of President Trump I suggest to
those persons they ought to write
letters their their own selves
expressing their beliefs but most of
those people declined and they don't
explain why not
I suspect they don't want their name in
the paper dairy farmer Marc Staal says
the decisive factor for him will be who
the Democratic contender is if the
candidate is too progressive he might
stick with Donald Trump even if that
means more suffering for him and the
farmers of Richland County and Tyson
Barker from the Aspen Institute Berlin
joins me now in the studio thanks for
being here Tyson what are the big issues
for American voters right now well it
really depends on on who you're talking
about which voter for the Democratic
voters the number one issue is health
care followed by the economy climate
change taxes education for Republican
voters it still remains immigration
security trade also the economy also for
Democratic voters the number one issue
that keeps coming up in all these these
debates that keep occurring is who can
beat Donald Trump and that's a really
ephemeral quality because that's all
based on you know their policies on the
way they come forward as a leader etc
but you're really seeing a very
segmented
population it depends on the state it
depends on your interest as we just
heard you know dairy farmers and farmers
across America are hurting because of
the trade war so that's gonna have an
impact there's a lot of issues out there
yeah
big country how is the big country
looking at the impeachment process and
how is that gonna hurt or help
democratic or republican candidates so
far the impeachment process has still
been a lot of inside baseball you've had
these depositions that have taken place
behind closed doors Republicans have
been pushing a line that's you know a
critique of the process saying that it
hasn't been transparent enough now there
has been a vote to go forward with the
impeachment inquiry in public with
hearings where they'll call these
witnesses to testify in public so now
the process will become a lot more out
in the open the question is really a
question of timing how long is this
impeachment process going to last in the
house and then how long is the trial
going to last in the Senate if we
conclude this whole process before the
end of the year which both the house and
the Senate are looking to do then this
won't probably be an issue next year
unless of course he has impeached and
removed
okay now coming back to the Democrats
the first test of the potential
Democratic candidates popularity comes
in Iowa and New Hampshire in a few
months as you know right what are the
first indications from the polls as to
who might be a front-runner
so again great bellwether States very
interesting states overwhelmingly white
states overwhelmingly rural states and
where you stand is where you sit a
little bit in in Iowa the Democratic
population tends to be a little more
liberal there's a big college population
there and it's essentially a four-way
horse race all for the top candidates
are between 22 and 18 percent that's
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders Joe
Biden and Pete Buddha touch and Biden
has been slipping in in Iowa which is
somewhat of a problematic indicator for
him in other states going forward in New
Hampshire it's a lot more about
geography so we have senator Bernie
Sanders from Vermont the neighboring
state and Elizabeth Warren from
Massachusetts the neighboring state both
have a lot of infrastructure that they
can flood into the state to kind of
bring up their support in New Hampshire
so this is going to be quite interesting
to see where this goes but again those
states are not reflective the entire
population more nationally which is
what's quite interesting is Biden's
support continues to melt away but his
base of support continues to be among
african-americans and the primary in
South Carolina is going to be decisive
in that okay Tyson Barker from yes and
Aspen Institute Berlin thank you for
that thank you